many scientific philosophical
discoveries occurred from
a correct concise phrasing of the
question that contains the problem
and not from
initially conceptualizing the solution
that is to say do you believe that the
framing of the question is often the
most important step in the discovery of
the solution to that question i do think
that that's the case
many of the times often in mathematics
there's a phrase that says make your
definitions complex and your proofs
simple
which means once you have the correct
idea of what you're
playing around with
then the proofs become trivial
and so certain questions like
well how was god there before anyone
else how does the cause list happen and
so on i don't know of how
the quote unquote how is the correct
frame
and to me it would be like saying what
time is the pen
or or how is the panoply
well what the heck does that mean it
perhaps it works at a syntactic level
but not as a semantic one like the
chomsky an idea of green colorless ideas
that sleep furiously i believe was it so
the mystic may say that one doesn't need
to do all of these verbal gymnastics
it's all a distraction and
rupert spyro might be on that they
feel like that because they're already
on a spiritual bend but there are large
swaths of the population the majority
perhaps not the minority but at least a
sizable portion 30 percent maybe greater
that aren't attracted to the eastern and
and mystical
method of knowing and that one doesn't
feel like the answer is i just need to
simply experience life and meditate away
into a blissful sea of nothingness so
30 percent of the population may feel
like oh yes i do need to do that like i
can see that there's some truth to it
but they they don't do it they can't do
it they don't feel like that's
it doesn't jive with them and maybe they
don't know how to do i don't know how to
do that not all the time i've had
certain experiences like that so maybe
they don't have a reason
to do so enough to motivate them and to
find the how
the
toe podcast and the discord and the
community and so on is
somewhat helps with this or at least it
comes in and it's the toe project or the
toe channel is like a process of
explication of a of a left a left brain
investigation of a of a right brain
phenomenon it's not because we disregard
the the right brain the experiential
it's
it's it's because we see the importance
of it we just don't have a
a ship to sail us from here to that
island to move us from our island to
another one the ships that work for
other people when people say hey all you
need to do is just meditate and just do
so and so they they don't work they
don't work for
for the logical analytical brain at
least not for many people like i said
perhaps 30 percent of people that's in
part what attracts that
thirty percent or i think a subset of
that thirty percent to the toe podcast
because
at least we're admitting that it just
doesn't jive with us
what i'm doing is trying to construct my
own boat and perhaps show by example how
others can construct their boat and they
can show me at least in the comment
section and on the discord and so on how
we can sail
to the promised land
by constructing a boat that is
is unexampled it's just for us it's
particular
and i see the utility in the
experiential approach i also see the
utility in the marriage between the
experiential and the analytical and so
many of those in the analytical will
disregard
the experiential so many in the
experiential will contem and disparage
the the analytical and say each one is
not needed only my approach well perhaps
perhaps so
or
what's more likely is perhaps that's
worked for you
and what what works for you doesn't
necessarily work for everyone else and
we all see this what
i think we're all well i think many of
us are
are tired of being told
that what one should do is
simply meditate in this manner and
simply realize quote unquote
quote-unquote awaken awakened
quote-unquote
loss of ego quote-unquote loss of self
and many of these
misappropriated if i could use that word
misappropriated terms from the east
which actually are heavily laden in the
culture of the east and then they're
adopted in the west usually via some
psychedelic
insight
completely disentangled from the
communities of the east if you
told them your insights from
psychedelics they say oh my gosh you're
completely misguided that's not what we
meant at all you have misunderstood
you've taken a translation mistranslated
it mistranslated and then adopted it
into english singularly when it should
have been from the source from our
culture in our culture with multiple
people and it's not just an insight that
you get alone it's something you work
through with a
with a with a sangha is what diana
pasoka said with a community of people
so
perhaps there's something
amiss with the analytical approach
perhaps there's something amiss with the
experiential approach but perhaps
there's utility in both and perhaps
there's utility in the marriage between
them
slo says do you have a synthesis of the
top concepts and theories you've learned
from your guests it's all disconnected
currently and you i need to spend more
time integrating rather than
rather than learning and then going on
to the next one and then learning and
learning